تخبر هذه الصور قصة ذئب
يقترب من حديقة منزلية متنقلة في
منتصف نهار الأسبوع الماضي ، بن ويلسون ، موظف
هناك مندهشًا من حجمه ، لم يكن
يشبه أي ذئب رأيته من قبل
وكان الأمر متروكًا لصدري  خمسة وثمانية ،
كان الأمر متروكًا لمعدتي على الأقل وحيث يوجد
واحد هناك عادة اثنان تحقق من
هذا الفيديو للزوج الذي شوهد يهرول
على طول ذئب مشروع Trail القريب وقد
شاهد مقاطع الفيديو والصور المنشورة
عبر الإنترنت وأبلغت
إدارة الأسماك في كاليفورنيا و  عادةً ما لا تُرى هذه الحيوانات
الهجينة أو ذئاب الكوي في
الغرب من المسيسيبي أبدًا ، وهي
ليست حدثًا طبيعيًا هي
أن شيئًا من صنع الإنسان
نجمعها معًا لصنع
نوع من الهجين لماذا يتجولون
الآن في بعض التكهنات بالفيضانات أو حرائق الغابات
أثرت على المحميات أو
أطلقها أصحابها على
السكان البرية في تلك المنطقة لاستنشاق
الحلول لأن رؤية الذئاب أو
أي شيء يخرجون خلال النهار كان
مقلقًا بعض الشيء